If you always want to have milk producers
and produce milk in France,
we will have to give a vision that is attractive
and it goes through the price.
Because the price allows
of income.
It also allows you to have a life that is like the whole society
because we are not outside of society.
So are we,
we are well in society.
We also have families that are in society.
We must be able to have time
with our
children,
with our family.
We must have time for ourselves too,
to breathe.
We work 7 days a week.
You also need income to be able to
hiring of the workforce
to have this flexibility in the organization.
And we also have everything that is ecological transition,
environmental,
to be implemented.
We are the first conscious
of what we have already done because we still
have the most sustainable agriculture.
We have to remember, right.
It must be called non-stop.
I don't think we say it enough:
we have the most respectful agriculture in the environmental world and
it must be called non-stop.
You have to stop getting pushed in
because environmental extremists have installed the idea
that farmers were the polluters of the environment.
We're in the crazy house.
It is therefore necessary to
let's remind him non-stop:
French agriculture is the most respectful in the environmental world.
Each time,
to protect the planet,
substitute a product of French agriculture rather than a
product of another agriculture,
that's the best we have to do
when you are in France to protect the environment.
It's important to say that.
For all this,
it is necessary to
that the food is paid at its fair value.
It allows us to do this work that we are already on
the most advanced.